Hello.
We know that the modern B2B selling has
evolved significantly.
The uncomfortable truth is that by the
time the buyer reaches you,
the decision is mostly made.
They've researched,
compared, and probably shortlisted
vendors or partners that they want to
work with.
That may include you or your
competitors.
This talk is about the architecture that
lets GTM teams know the buyer more than
they today.
My name is Sajjan Khan Akolanu. I have
20-plus years experience across product,
technology, and marketing.
At Position Squared, as the VP of global
operations and strategy, I lead the
services teams
and our AI-native transformation from
vision to positioning to deployment,
where I work closely with our technology
team.
We've launched 75-plus AI agents
specifically for our clients,
18-plus vertical knowledge bases that
power these agents, and we've had
800-plus runs per month, and this is
data as of month-to-date June 2026.
By the time we get to the end of the
year, I expect these numbers to increase
significantly.
The interesting thing about GTM and AI
is that many GTM teams try to bolt AI
onto their existing stack or existing
processes and workflows.
And therein lies the problem.
That approach itself is hindrance to
scale.
The interesting thing though is there
are three different problems that GTM
leaders and GTM teams have to solve in
order to be successful in this AI era.
And these three are number one, AI.
By just bolting AI onto your existing
systems, AI doesn't really and cannot
really find out
who your buyer is.
It doesn't understand their role. It
doesn't understand their history. It
doesn't understand their intent
stand-alone.
That's number one.
Number two is the integration itself.
The old GTM stacks may not necessarily
be best positioned to capture all the
intent signals and the data, the CRM
context context that the AI captures on
its own and bring that all together. So,
the systems today as they stand may be
broken.
By putting AI on top of it
is not going to help solve the problem.
The third is the architecture.
The underlying architecture has to
evolve
with AI at the core. And I'll talk about
what I mean by that in a little bit, but
the fundamental concept here is that
with AI bolted on to your existing GTM
systems, processes, and workflows,
you will not be able to scale.
And
most GTM deployments
do not solve for all these three
problems simultaneously. You could
accomplish one and two, but if three is
not accomplished or you don't solve for
number three, then you still have a
problem. So, it is important that all
these three problems are solved
together.
And I will show you an architecture
diagram in just a bit that's going to
walk you through how we do it at
Position Squared.
Another problem that we face is that
with the buyer.
The buyers are constantly evolving.
And what I mean by that is by the time
the buyer reaches out to you in today's
world, they're not early stage. They're
actually late stage.
Here are some stats to prove that point.
94% of buyers use GenAI as a primary
research.
And these platforms are almost like a
black box where we don't know what they
consumed, what they read about,
who they've investigated, if your
organization is on top of that list or
not.
And that is
information that is from the Forrester
2026 research.
The second stat is about 67% of B2B
buyers prefer a rep-free experience.
They don't want to talk to people as
they make the decision.
80% of deals
very interesting statistic. 80% of deals
go to the buyers
who are part of the pre-contact list.
So, essentially, buyers have already
made up their mind.
And the fourth and very vital stat here
is only 17%
only 17% of the total buying time
is spent talking with potential vendors.
What all these numbers tell us is the
buyers do their research thoroughly.
They use various tools including the
GenAI platforms.
And by the time they come talk with you
or come to your website, they have made
up their mind.
Now, imagine a situation where the buyer
does that research, comes to your
website, and you have a chat window
for them to engage with so they can
converse with your very intelligent AI
system.
That is now responsible for telling them
about what you have to offer and how
they can buy your services or product.
But many
GTM systems that are bolted with AI
would essentially start off with a
conversation that would be something
like this.
How can I help you?
What is it that you would like to What
is it that you would like to know today?
But these are questions that actually
move you backwards.
They don't move you forward as an
organization.
The buyer has done their research and
then some basic questions are asked to
them.
They're actually walking out of the
system.
They're not continuing their
conversation. So, it is very important
that as a seller
you know what the buyer's needs are, you
know who the buyer is, you know who the
buyer is, who what their buying needs
are,
and you're able to cater to those as
they engage on your site.
So, what does this really mean
when it comes to implementing an
architecture? How does one accomplish an
architecture or a system where the buyer
information is known
as soon as they come to your site?
There are essentially three architecture
layers behind an intelligent system
and running an intelligent GTM.
The first is signals.
This includes all the communication and
information coming from your CRM
systems, which includes your information
about the deals, your contacts, who the
owner or the sales rep is for that, who
are you conversing with.
It also includes an enrichment system
where
you have the right information pulled
out of these anonymous visitors that are
hitting your site.
This system is going to work as long as
that information is accurate. If you're
off on the enrichment,
your data is off, and so is your
communication.
And one of the things that we find
really helpful and really useful, very
important, is signals coming out of
social media platforms.
Especially LinkedIn, what we find is the
engagement, the job changes
are huge signals
for you to capture as an organization,
which we do as ourselves, and I'll show
you what what I mean by that.
And these these signals really help
identify
how and who you should target and when.
So, for example, if you have an exact
sponsor at your current account,
and that individual is leaving the
organization
and moving into another account,
and that company is not part of your
list.
Given that you have this exact sponsor
currently as your contact,
you ought to make sure that the company
that they're moving to next is part of
your account list, and they become your
new exec sponsor, your champion in that
organization.
That's the power of social signals, and
it's very important that these are
captured, and not many companies
leverage this in a automated, systematic
way. And I'll talk about how to how to
do that in just a second.
The second layer is that of buyer
intelligence.
This is about making sure you have the
right information about the buyer. It
all starts with
for us, at least at Position Squared,
and we believe
uh this is how it should be for a lot of
organizations,
is through a knowledge base.
A knowledge base is a repository of
context that you have about your
product, your buyers, the ICPs, the
personas, the different titles,
different playbooks, different criteria
of success.
Everything that makes you successful
sits in a knowledge base.
It also has visitor
identity information, de-anonymized
information sitting in your
buyer intelligence database.
The ICP scoring, what defines a score,
uh uh what score defines a fit,
and what score defines a buying stage
versus someone who's a research mode.
All these are things you hope to
quantify within your buyer intelligence
system.
Then you have a context builder.
All the signals that you have need to
form a context graph that I'll talk
about next.
And then,
you need to have a routing logic.
This is where you would define what
message goes to who, when. So, if
someone were to engage with you on
LinkedIn,
do they get a LinkedIn outreach, or do
they get an email? Or should they be
shown an ad?
Um these are the insights or inputs that
actually go as part of your routing
logic.
The third layer is that of action.
Once you have the signals and
information and the intelligence from
the first two layers,
now it's time for action, which
basically means now you have when user
lands on your
uh page or your website,
the chat window that popped up earlier
that I talked about shouldn't ask
generic questions like what can I help
you with?
What are you looking for? What's your
name? That's not the communication at
this point. The communication's
personalized and I'll show you an
example what I mean by that.
It needs to identify the user, address
them by name,
and talk about where they potentially
left off last time they were on your
site.
Or based on the intent signals, the chat
needs to offer them specific content.
The action also based on these signals
should be about sending the right alerts
and information to the rep.
Too many,
you lose the the rep, the sales rep, and
too few, you're not helping them hit
their
hit their numbers. Um and and get
revenue for the organization.
The third piece here is that of updating
the CRM. The CRM system cannot just be
an update about the contacts that the
sales had. It needs to be about the
context
on about the account that
the first two layers drive for you.
And finally,
the sequence trigger.
The actions need to determine what type
of outreach sequence need to be sent out
at what time.
What outreach is triggered when, to who?
Without all these three layers running
in tandem,
the GTM model is still obsolete, is old
school, and it's not set for the AI era
that we are talking about.
And here's an example of context graph.
All the signals we just talked about
roll into this connected record,
which is per buyer.
The persona, account, and deal,
these are all signals and actions that
are logged for every touch point across
the account
for every single person.
A person's signals
link to their account.
The accounts have multiple people in
them.
So, the buying committee information
surfaces for the account based on the
signals coming by person and for each
account.
Then, you have deal level information
here,
which is very specific to sales and
marketing activities. So, has sales and
has marketing already reached out to
this individual or people the buying
committee at this account?
And all these together
with all those signals and data points
and touch points become a context graph.
The reason why a context graph is
important is because without it, you
don't know which account is a priority
and which one is not.
And therefore, when you have this
information, you're able to prioritize
the high
intent accounts and contacts within
those accounts for your sales team and
marketing to pursue.
Now, having covered the architecture
and the importance of a
context graph,
I want to walk you through
how we implement this architecture and
what that flow looks like, followed by a
quick demo of what our system shows us
when it comes to all the details that I
just talked about and how our system
helps us identify key accounts and key
stakeholders that we need to reach out
to.
This is how the three-layered
architecture I just talked about looks
like as connected agents.
When a user lands on our site,
at that moment we don't know who they
are. They're anonymous.
And that is when
that visit kicks off the first job,
which is the identification job.
And as you'll notice, I'm using more
than one source here running together,
and that's because no single tool
catches every visitor.
We pull the information provided by
these tools, consolidate them, and
dedupe them, and send it over to the
next layer,
which is the enrichment phase.
These tools change all the time for us,
but not necessarily the architecture as
such.
Once these contacts are enriched,
the next layer, which is the
intelligence layer, kicks in.
Here you'll notice
that our ICP filter agent kicks in,
which is referencing information from
the knowledge base. What this does at
this stage is
it's looking back at the knowledge base
and making sure that the contacts that
come in are part of the criteria we've
defined in our knowledge base.
Anything that doesn't fit,
such as wrong industry or wrong geo,
wrong size, wrong persona,
are weeded out.
Those contacts and information are
deleted.
What fits our criteria and what's
relevant
moves into a clean table of qualified
accounts.
After this,
the match agent kicks in.
It checks for people against our CRM.
Have we talked to them? Are they warm?
Are they hot? That's the evaluation that
happens at this stage.
Finally, the action agent kicks in.
This agent decides what happens next
per person.
And this could include
one person from
an account or if there's a buying
committee,
the actions are decided for the entire
buying committee per account.
Here, the action agent
decides different alerts
that the sales reps have to get on Slack
with the right context and a draft of an
email that they can possibly send.
This agent also decides if an email has
to be fired up and sent over to the
contacts we have.
It also decides if we need to
use LinkedIn for an outreach.
And this is how the workflow works
from the three-layered architecture to
how we implement GTM agents today at
Position Squared.
Now, let me walk you through
how the system actually looks in the
back end.
So, we saw the three-layered
architecture. We saw the agents
working together.
Now, what does the output look like is
what I'll show next.
Here's a view of our system at Position
Squared, which is called Intelligence.
What you see here is as soon as I land,
the system is able to
understand who I am and I see a
personalized message
coming up here as part of our chat
interface.
Instead of just asking me generic
questions, it's actually pointing me to
one of the conversations that I had with
it earlier and prompting me or asking me
if I want to continue there. And if I
were to say yes,
it pulls up a link or gives me a link
here, which I can click on and go to the
specific conversation that I was
uh part of earlier.
What you see here is a culmination of
all the signals, information,
and all the data that we collected as
part of the user
that is reflected here in the chat. So,
as opposed to having a generic greeting
for me, this is more personalized.
Let me now take you to
our internal dashboard
and show you how this data actually
is projected to us when we
look at the accounts that we
are pursuing.
Here's a view of the interface that gets
us into our dashboard.
What you have here is two
key sections that we have built. One is
for GTM, the other is organic. For our
conversation today, I'll be walking you
through what happens when we go to our
GTM dashboard.
Once you enter the dashboard, what you
see are multiple cards.
And for the conversation today, I will
be focusing on the anonymous visitors
and the LinkedIn intelligence sections.
What do you see here is when I click on
the anonymous visitors, it takes us to a
dashboard where
the flow of agents and the architecture
that I showed you earlier
is de-anonymizing the users. It's
identifying the users that come onto our
website, and it's categorizing them into
multiple sections. What you see here is
we have our system has identified about
3,000 odd people or visitors coming in
from about 280 different accounts. And
the system tells us that information
technology is one of the key verticals
or key industries that's visiting our
site.
And this is in fact one of the verticals
that we focus on. What you also see is
the industry breakdown, as well as hot
signals. And this is information of
people
from different companies
that are being categorized as
hot contacts or hot accounts at this
point. This is a combination of
different signals including the
conversations that have happened within
HubSpot.
For the sake of the conversation here, I
have changed the names although the
titles are accurate.
If I were to scroll down, I have more
information about these users, about the
contacts,
the companies they belong to,
the location,
as well as industry type.
All this information
is
uh or or can be sorted. All this
information can be sorted
based on industry, seniority, different
types of engagements they've had with
us.
And we can also look at the companies
that visit our site.
The second part of this is if I were to
go to the LinkedIn intelligence,
and this is the part that many GTM teams
miss.
LinkedIn has a wealth of information
that is very useful.
What you see here is over the last few
days about 100 people visited our site
through
LinkedIn
from 73 different companies and they've
engaged with eight different posts that
we put out recently.
It has a list of all the
folks that have engaged and the type of
engagement they've had with us. We can
actually sort them out by C-suite, VPs,
directors, managers, and individual
contributors. Those are the categories
that we use.
And you have a list of companies where
they belong to.
By clicking on each of these, we can
actually go into very specific details
about their overall engagement with us.
This level of detail really helps
us
bring in the right level of intelligence
into our system.
Now that we've looked at the
architecture, let me walk you through
what
does tend to break when it comes to
building these types of systems. And I
want to focus on four key areas. The
first is the ICP drift, and this is
real. Your ICPs evolve over time. For
example, today you focus on a $20 AR
organization from a certain vertical,
and if you were to close a $50 or $100
AR firm
from a different vertical, then you
might realize that that is a new area
for you to focus on and for you to
pursue. And that information is critical
to enter into your knowledge base.
Without that, your agents are working
off of the old information, always
giving you wrong wrong data that you
might not want.
What this means is you need to retrain
your models.
You retrain your agents every quarter
with your closed one or closed lost
opportunities. And this is critical.
Without this, your agents are looking at
wrong information, pointing you to the
wrong accounts and the wrong people.
The second point is alert fatigue.
If everything is flagged as hot to a
sales rep, they would stop acting
because it's it just gets overwhelming
for them.
And at that moment, they stop trusting
the system and the system's dead.
So, it's important to use the knowledge
base and the context graph to cut
through the noise and focus on the
alerts.
Focus on alerts from the accounts
and contacts that do actually matter for
the sales people to act upon.
The third item is identity ceiling.
And this is a limit that exists with
tools today.
A lot of these platforms, when it comes
to identifying the anonymous visitors,
they're almost 70% or a little more than
70% accurate when it comes to company
identification. They're only about 15 to
20% accurate when it comes to individual
identification. And this is a structural
limit
and a structural issue with these
systems.
The only way to truly maximize this
is to keep testing different systems
till
you hit on one that gives you a much
better numbers than what you already
have.
But most important thing here is to keep
these metrics in mind as you plan your
GTM outreach.
And finally, the human bottleneck.
The minute the approval queue feels like
a chore,
it's going to become
backlogged. It's going to be ignored and
the system is not going to be trusted
anymore.
What this means is you need to make sure
that you shrink the friction
between
let's say a draft email that's ready to
be sent
to that being sent.
And what I mean is
if your draft email is in a spot where
it's almost ready to go with very minor
edit,
and you're able to kick it out with just
one click,
then that's a system that's going to
sustain.
But if the time taken to edit an email
that the AI writes
is, let's say, longer than we look at 30
seconds. If it's longer than 30 seconds,
then this is
a dead initiative because
the sales would then rather focus on
drafting their own email as opposed to
trusting what the system gives them.
Finally, I want to leave you with four
key takeaways. One, you have to start
with the identity.
Not being able to identify visitors who
who land on your site
is as good as a dead GTM project.
What you need is a system that's put in
place, just like what I showed you
earlier or something similar to that,
that is robust enough to identify the
visitors coming to your website
and has a feedback mechanism where that
information is able to go back into your
knowledge base and vice versa.
The second is the score fit and intent
needs to be looked at separately.
Conflating them
is going to send the wrong message to
the wrong person.
The third is you need to have a policy
engine that is auditable and adjustable.
What it means is you need to have a
system where if it doesn't work, you
have a way to audit
which agent or what part of the
workflow, for example, like the one that
I just showed you, is broken and you
have a way to go fix it
as opposed to going after a developer to
help you come fix it.
So, you need to build a system where as
a GTM
leader or a GTM team member, you are
able to control the system and fix it
when needed.
Because things do break quite frequently
when it comes to AI and managing the
output from AI.
Finally,
you need to let the flywheel compound.
What I mean by that is every send, every
reply, and every closed deal
should make the model smarter, should
make your system smarter.
What it means is any information about
wins, losses,
deferred sales, all that needs to go
back into your knowledge base and your
agents need to be able to capture that
information to make the right decision
for the future.
That's all I have for you today. Thank
you very much for your time.